Larry, the CEO of a major computer parts manufacturer, has been feeling frustrated.
Business was good thus far because he offered high-quality products at a fair price...
...and he maintained a close relationship with his clients.
But the number of competitors increased because of globalization.
Because of their strong offerings, Larry could no longer compete on price and quality.
He can't find any other way to lower cost or improve on quality.
How can he overcome this crisis?
Hello everyone, my name is Rich Scott.
Many B2B companies face similar problems as that of Larry's company.
In the past, all B2B companies had to focus on...
...was offering good quality products at a fair price with on time delivery.
Simply put, QCD.
And building a good relationship with clients through good sales skills put the cherry on top.
However, that's not enough anymore.
As technology levels off, competitors are making similar products at similar prices.
In other words, the era of competing with quality and price has ended.